so I mentioned to the internet that I'm
talking to you and so the internet gave
some questions so I apologize for these
but do you think we're living in a
simulation that the universe is a
computer or the universe is the
computation running a computer it's
conceivable what I don't buy is you know
you'll have the argument that well let's
say that it was the case that you can
have simulations then the simulated
world would itself eventually get to a
point where it's running simulations yes
and then the the second layer down would
create a third layer down and on and on
and on so probabilistically you just
throw a dart at one of those layers
we're probably in one of the simulated
layers I think if there's some sort of
limitations
unlike the information processing of
whatever the physical world is like it
quickly becomes the case that you have a
limit to the layers that could exist
there because like the resources
necessary to simulate a universe like
ours
clearly is a lot just in terms of the
number of bits at play and so then you
can ask well what's more plausible that
there's an unbounded capacity of
information processing in whatever they
like highest up level universe is or
that there's some bound to that capacity
which then limits like the number of
levels available how do you play some
kind of probability distribution on like
what the information capacity is I have
no idea but I I don't mean like people
almost assume a certain uniform
probability over all of those metal
layers that could conceivably exist when
it's a little bit like a Pascal's wager
on like you're not giving a low enough
prior to the mere existence of that
infinite set of layers yeah that's true
but it's also very difficult to
contextualize the amount so the amount
of information processing power required
to simulate like our universe seems like
amazingly huge what you can always raise
two to the power of that exactly yeah
like numbers bit big and we're easily
humbled but basically everything around
us so it's very difficult to to kind of
make sense of anything actually when you
look up at the sky and look at the stars
in the immensity of it all to make sense
of us the smallness of us the
unlikeliness of
everything that's on this earth coming
to be then you could basically anything
could be all laws of probability go out
the window to me because I guess because
the amount of information under which
we're operating is very low we basically
know nothing about the world around us
relatively speaking and so so when I
think about the simulation hypothesis I
think is just fun to think about it but
it's also I think there is a thought
experiment kind of interesting to think
of the power of computation where there
are the limits of a Turing machine sort
of the limits of our current computers
when you start to think about artificial
intelligence how far can we get with
computers and that's kind of where the
simulation hypothesis useless me as a
thought experiment is is the universe
just the computer is it just a
computation is all of this just a
computation and so the same kind of
tools we apply to analyzing algorithms
can that be applied you know if we scale
further and further and further
well the arbitrary power of those
systems start to create some interesting
aspects that we see in our universe or
as something fundamentally different
needs to be created well it's
interesting that in our universe it's
not arbitrarily large the power that you
can place limits on for example how many
bits of information can be stored per
unit area right like all of the physical
laws we've got general relativity and
lie quantum coming together to give you
a certain limit on how many bits you can
store within a given range before it
collapses into a black hole like the
idea that there even exists such a limit
is that the very least thought-provoking
when naively you might assume oh well
you know technology could always get
better and better we could get cleverer
and cleverer and you could just cram as
much information as you want into like a
small unit of space that makes me think
it's at least plausible that whatever
the highest level of existence is
doesn't admit too many simulations or
ones that are at the scale of
complexity that we're looking at
obviously it's just as conceivable that
they do and that there are many but I I
guess what I'm channeling is the
surprise that I felt upon learning that
fact that there are the information is
physical in this way
you